join me now for vague ramaswami 2024
Republican presidential candidate Vivek
great to see you in studio what do you
think is going on here like is a
contingency plan among the Democrats
being seriously considered given all
these little guide posts this week
absolutely and I've been saying this for
a long time Laura I don't think they're
going to let President Biden run against
someone like me in a general election
the contrast would be too Stark and I
think that's what these charges are all
about right you see right when Biden's
popularity begins to dip that's when
they bring that first indictment not in
the real thing that they should indict
honor Biden for but for the for the
felony gun charges not the foreign
selling off of our foreign policies yeah
I think I like that tweet so I think
that the what they're going to do is the
documents case that's hanging and that's
hovering too they're going to pull that
out when Biden refuses to step aside
that's when the Deep State the federal
police state exercises their leverage
over him and that's a two for one for
them because they then get to legitimize
their prosecution of trump claim aiming
that it's even handed across partisan
boundaries when in fact the real divide
isn't partisan at all it is between the
managerial class in the Deep State and
the everyday citizens I mean when you
say managerial class I mean the people
who were never elected actually the
people who the bureaucrats the
bureaucrats I call them bureaucrats is
that your generation you call them
managerial State you know we can
multiple different words Shadow
government deep state three letter
agency Friday night I'm trying to you
know it's I think you're on point all
the time you've got your points we're a
serious subject matter so Vivek when you
look at you where you are where DeSantis
is you guys are kind of neck and neck
and then you got Trump all together you
all are about 84 of the Republican
electorate so I was dying laughing this
week when Romney's up there God bless
him and he's talking about how he's
retiring anything well essentially I'm
paraphrasing when the party returns to
you know its old base it's old clear
clear principles then there'll be room
for people like me you guys are 84 of
the party that's a populist just more
you know America focused party so I do
think the America first movement is the
new Republican that was the old guard is
gone right the Old Guard is gone and in
fact much of the democratic party is I
think now taking some chapter and verse
out of that old school Republican party
when it comes to foreign policy and
other issues but I do think the America
first movement is the only way forward
for the Republican party and I think we
have a legitimate debate Laura around
who's going to be best positioned to
carry that Banner forward but I think
the data are clear the three of us are
speaking actually at an event later
tonight which is why I'm in DC that is
the future do you like when you see him
do you kind of chit chat with them for a
while let's see if we see each other
backstage you know we're friendly how
are you doing Vivek you're looking good
love your hair you know I I like I like
both those guys in this race and I
respect aspects about both of them I do
think it will take somebody to reach
young voters to win this in a landslide
why don't you drop out and just support
Trump well frankly I think I can I can
unite this country in a way that I think
no one else can he's up 45 points on you
and DeSantis well I mean I'm just I'm
just doing The Devil's Advocate thing
we love Ron they're both Governor
DeSantis they're both I mean you're new
to this game you're a young guy you're
new to this game Ron DeSantis is tested
he's a tested guy but both of you
together
I mean people if you've about both
dropped out and just said you know
Donald Trump is obviously the guy most
people want and we we're going to put
our country before ourselves we're going
to support them well the fact of the
matter is I think the country is best
off when we have a vigorous legitimate
debate within our party about who's
going to best carry forward that agenda
and I think Laura this can't be a 50.1
election I don't think we have that in a
country
it's got to be a wave and I think that
we're bringing young people along the
Next Generation along I think for a long
time we have been running from something
now is Our Moment to start running to
something and I think being a true
Outsider in this race and I think you
only get to be an outsider once is my
advantage I think people are going to
want that they love hitting you like
they I say they who's they well Business
Insider they had this report on you this
week and they say former employees said
that you used to have them set the
thermostats at 64 degrees and you were
you ridiculed the idea of Summer Fridays
I love that that you're ready I hate the
summer Friday dress you wants White
Glove service from staffers meaning you
have a high bar and thinks people are
not put on this Earth to serve him
people are on this Earth to serve him so
you know people are hitting you you're
neurotic you're you're Mercurial and
you're a paranoid leader do any of those
things describe you you know I think
that that's a pretty unfair
characterization but there's some truth
to the fact that I am very demanding
Laura of the people around me I work
18-hour days they've said that of me too
I think Sam don't say anything my rule
of thumb is I don't hold anybody who is
standard that I don't hold myself but
those are high standards you work hard
you don't achieve things in this country
without hard work that isn't American
value and I don't apologize and you're
never going to turn liberal you're gonna
you're never gonna be pro-chine all
right you're never gonna you know be
dead set dead set for this country part
of what gets us at in this country is
hard work and dedication put the
citizens of this country first I don't
talk to zelinski I'd rather talk to Maui
that's the kind of American president
I'm looking to be I think it's what we
need it's great to have you in studio
man it's good to see you first time in
person exactly great to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
honest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else